Don't you guys know that Lauren de Lagona has made tweets and
Reddit posts with ellipses,
some of length three, some of length four, and this is proof
that I was set up from the beginning. >> This ends with
four. She likes to present this story that she was like forced
to go public on January 20th. No, I'd say she's probably more
forced to do this one by like the act of you leaking to her non-consensually,
but two, refusing to speak with her privately or talk to her
privately and saying like, "Get a lawyer. Go off. Get a lawyer."
He likes to present this story as if she was forced to go public.
As if she didn't know that her stuff was going to be blown up
publicly. Obviously, he's going to show us evidence that like
she was working with Sunday or Becket, right? Oh, but tourniquet,
he got the details wrong is the funny thing. You got the details
very wrong because he's a conspiratorial
like tourniquet.
How long do you think it took for them to file the complaint
after Pixie sent that
Cuz Destiny seems to think that it was like the next day.
That's not true. It was a month after this. Why would Pixie be
okay with those Sunday videos getting released if it was gonna
take her a month to send any anything to do with her litigation?
Like I I forget where this is. This is at some point where basically
Eriday was talking to him and he he said like, "No, no, no. She
should just get a lawyer if she wants to continue this, right?"
I think it's in the follow-up stream.
>> So, it was going to be published. The idea that those
videos forced it was >> like after you're talking to somebody
about helping them financially and then you block them because
of the messages they're sending and say just you tell like a
she can get a lawyer if she wants to do this, right?
I think at that point you probably know there might be some litigation
coming. That's not shocking. it's that she is forced to go public
with it when Sunday and Becket go out with their videos.
>> Um, it's also obvious at this point she's not taking
any advice from Aaron, probably because Lauren is writing all
of this for her. Uh, update, she sent me a statement she wants
to publish, but it's terrible. I think it's too long. Blah blah
blah. Right. So, um,
>> she's also saying back here, um, now this I don't know
what the date of these messages are. I'm guessing it's the same
day, but on January 8th,
Erin is asking, >> I forget what this is all about. We'll
>> What day were you thinking about releasing it? Pixie
says, um, in response to something else. No, I don't think he'd
do that because I think it would look worse. I mean, anything
you guys have. No, I mean, the most I can think of is the Virginia
stuff or NS, but I have trouble seeing how he would do that in
a way that doesn't make him look worse for trying to deflect.
I don't even know what they're talking about here. And then,
so in response to, "What day do we think about releasing it?"
Pixie says, "Could have talked to my lawyer first, send a demand
letter, and based on his response to said letter, release it.
I originally wanted to do it by next week, but it seems unlikely."
So, again, this was like always the plan. >> Yeah, it was
always the plan probably to go like the legal route. Yeah, that's
true. But I don't think I don't think Pixie even disputed that.
It was that they ended up getting caught like offguard, right?
I don't think I don't think they ever disputed that they were
going to sue or that she was looking to sue because that's in
the logs. It would be to dispute that. I think the issue is that
they weren't ready to they weren't they didn't have their in
a row. They weren't even sure what they were suing for yet. Right.
I think that's actually what the issue is is she wasn't getting
it done. I don't know what she was doing. Probably just being
depressed.
Right. That's more where it is. I don't know why
Destiny often does this. He did this with like the Abbeby thing,
too, where he's like, "Dude, guys, they don't even have proof
of me sending the videos. She doesn't even have pictures of me
sending the videos." And it's like, "Yeah, but she never said
she did."
She little devil. I'm saying from like uh from January onward,
it was probably always the plan to I think she was going the
legal route, but that was like something that Destiny had cut
off all communication with her, right? So, she's probably always
going the legal route after January or after when they cut off
communic when he cuts off communication in December. I would
imagine she's always That's my interpretation from these messages
and what I've read. Right.
I don't think she was going to sue before that, but she's also
filing as Jane Doe. I don't know if that's relevant here, but
yeah.
>> Have I mentioned anything about
I don't know if I've said any of this publicly yet. Have I mentioned
anything about Pixie DMing me on
the 18th? >> This is why this is so good. Is I didn't know
about this. Now I understand how he thinks everything's a conspiracy,
right? Like it didn't make any sense to me. Like it seemed completely
insane, completely without reason. And now that he's like revealing
this, which is Pixie DM'd him on January 18th, two days before
those videos dropped, now I get why he like went that like at
least there's something there where I'm like, "Oh, he didn't
totally like his brain didn't totally shatter. It just it's kind
of broken, but at least it didn't totally shatter. Just wait
until he gets to it. He's he's teasing it, but he'll get to it."
So, I think that Lauren is helping her significantly and I think
that she knows that the court case they're filing, she admits
that at least one of the causes of action. Uh, so apparently
Pixie here saying, "Oh, I don't know if we can go under this
this like specific cause of action." Apparently, her saying that
is something that should be considered like a statement in court.
So, we should just accept, you know, based on Destiny's admission
that he is he's admitted he did all of these things. Right.
Right. He admitted it to Pixie. said, "I I violated her truck
in the worst way possible." He's like admitted to violating her
consent. Yes. >> The complaint would survive a motion to
dismiss without any evidence. So, remember, there's that one
thing that keeps getting said over and over again, like the a
supporter's sister or a supporter's friend or whatever. Okay.
Oh, actually, I should see in their amended complaint if that's
still there. That would actually be good to see. Let me see if
that's still in the amended complaint. I don't know if Cyber's
here right now, but if that's in the amended complaint, that
would be interesting. Hold on.
Amend. Oh god, that's Yes. Exhibit amended complaint.
Let's check this out. Sister
on January 20th, right after plaintiff announced publicly that
she would sue Banell, one of his followers reached out to Plaintiff
and told her that Banell had sent her the sent the video to her
to her sister about two months earlier. The follower informs
plaintiff that she believes Benell is still sending her sister
explicit videos of the other woman without their consent. So
this is in here, but it's not saying it's from a Kiwi Farms post,
right? So I would think if I were Destiny's legal team, probably
my strategy would be, oh, um, I want to subpoena the DMs with
this person, right? I would be like, hey, can we we want this
in discovery? You claim this happened. I want your evidence of
this that you actually talked to this person that you didn't
just copy a
like Kiwi Palms post. That's probably where you
Now, I might even be helping him here. If he if he really believes
this is Lauren de Lagona who made this story up, which is what
he's about to allege,
right? If he really believes that, then you should just subpoena
Pixie. You should be able to, hey, there's this thing in the
complaint. I can subpoena you for these DMs. Reach out to plaintiff,
right? That's didn't he? Well, I don't know if he subpoenaed
him for these DMs specifically, but he should. I don't think
we've seen any of the discovery requests. But if he really believes
that's Lauren de Laguda, then where did they reach out? Cuz that'll
be on a platform that keeps way better records than Kiwi Farms,
which is going to be his excuse here, by the way. No, the allegation
here is that a follower of Destiny reached out to Pixie and said,
"My sister has received videos and received your video two months
ago on January 20th." So, this would have been October 2024.
Uh, no. Kringle Kesh, this is a follower of
Destiny,
reached out to Pixie and said, "Hey, this person, this is hearsay,
but this is basically probably why it was like not
I think this claim is why they didn't throw this out on uh like
why they didn't try to file a motion to dismiss. I think it's
this claim,
which is a little crazy."
>> Okay, so he's about to we're about to go through this.
Let's let's continue. So on the 18th of January, Pixie sends
me some post on Kiwi Farms of a person saying this comment caused
me to create an account because I wanted to be known that he
Destiny has sent videos of himself having sex with Pixie to my
friend. Now they don't say sister, but they say to my friend.
I don't expect anyone to believe me without proof, but I am so
grossed by the actions.
So this is basically Destiny is saying this is like the same
story, right?
So this comment caused me to create an account. So something
else to consider. Rose won't have been the only person he was
doing this with. He would respond to and sent with with literally
any girl that messages him. So there will be more random e girls
with videos of Destiny's orbiters on their hard drive. And this
person says, "Hey, this comment made me make it made me or caused
me to create an account because I want it to be known that he
has sent videos of himself having sex with Pixie to my friend."
Oh, wait, hold on. This isn't the sister. Oh, he's actually he's
actually copying these things over.
Wait, wait. This is a totally Is this a totally different allegation?
Why did he say sister?
Cuz sister is in the
but this
is not the same allegation.
There's a different one.
Can I see sister in here? Oh.
>> Oh, he's Oh, this isn't even the same allegation.
So,
>> Pixie to my friend. I don't expect anyone to believe
me without proof. But I am so grossed out grossed by the actions.
I couldn't hold it in while watching people speculate this. He
is reckless at best and a predator at worst. I think he sends
these videos to make them feel like he's a viable partner because
he has sex with many girls. I feel so bad for Pixie and I hope
she gets the help she needs. My friend would never post the video,
but I don't know if he sent it to more people and what they would
do with it. Her face is clearly visible. Dot dot dot. Oh, keep
an eye on that dot dot dot. That's a very important dot dot dot.
Okay, that's a very important dot dot dot. He literally said
it didn't say sister. Okay, fine.
Well, he start he talked about the sister story, but this isn't
referenced for their thing. This explicitly is not referenced
for this
right? So this is not referenced in the the legal whatsoever,
>> right? This is not referenced in the in the legal complaint.
This isn't
>> at all. Okay. Very cuz he said he said sister earlier,
right?
>> To create an account. >> What is he going to say
about this? Because he said sister earlier and now somebody said
he said this doesn't say sister. So, on the 18th of January,
hold
>> Pixie sends me some post on Kiwi Farms of a person saying,
"This comment caused me to create an account because I wanted
to be known that he Destiny has sent videos of himself having
sex with Pixie to my friend." Now, they don't say sister, but
girls, but who the cares, I guess. Um, told me that video
to their sister just a few months ago. this individual and their
sister as well as other other individuals videos of himself having
sex with Pixie to my friend. Now they don't say sister but they
say to my friend >> I don't expect anyone to believe without
proof but I am so grossed by the actions. I couldn't hold it
in while watching people speculate this. He is reckless at best
and a predator at worst. I think he sends these videos to make
them feel like he's a viable partner because he has with many
girls. I feel so bad for Pixie and I hope she gets the help she
needs. My friend would never post the videos, but I don't know
if he sent this to uh more people and what they would do with
her. Her face is clearly visible. Dot dot dot.
So,
she sends me this message and then after she says, "I need you
about to wait, where's there's no explanation of the inconsistency.
He just says it's not the same >> to know how many people."
I'm not joking, Stephen. If something else >> No, this
is not this this is not used as a as something in the documents.
There's a different thing in the documents which he should be
able to subpoena,
right? He should be able to subpoena some amount some messages
where Pixie was sent these
right? That's the problem is is these aren't referenced. As far
as I can tell, these aren't referenced at all.
Unless they were just
unless they were just added, which maybe they're in the amended
complaint. Hold on. friend
ABMC message a friend of hers various friends random followers
point of unfriends banel banel's close friend associate Kyla
add her back as a friend
no it's not in here at all like they could have been two different
people yeah exactly that person deleted their account so no DMs
wait deleting your deleting your account doesn't mean no DMs
and it doesn't mean no DMs on your side there could still easily
be DMs there what why would there be no DMs because you deleted
your account, right? I don't that doesn't make any sense to me
at all.
Anyway,
>> else of mine gets leaked and I don't >> like at
minimum Pixie should have her responses or something like that,
right? >> The mental heads up/fortitude surrounding it.
I will 100% myself. I can't Why wouldn't Pixie sew those in docks?
Uh they're a part of a complaint and she doesn't have like an
affidavit. Nothing is in there that isn't in an affidavit. Nothing's
in the initial complaint. The initial complaint is just saying
what they what they've seen, right?
The whole point of the lawsuit is you give the initial complaint
and then Destiny's side can request discovery around those things.
>> Can't continue to live my life every morning, waking
up sick to my stomach, wondering if someone is going to blast
the most vulnerable and intimate parts of my life for thousands
to see. So, >> this is Pixie DMing him 9:28 p.m. on January
18th, 2025 or 9:24. on January 18th,
about a day day and a half before she they actually filed the
uh complaint. At the time, I just I thought I don't think so.
KF people are always going to >> Okay, this is maybe the
funniest part of this video.
Okay, what do you think Pixie thinks when she's like, "Okay,
man. I need to know brass tax here. Okay, I'm not joking around.
If anything else gets leaked,
I'm going to end it. All right, tell me right now. Did anything
else happen?" And he goes, "I don't think so. I don't think,
dude, what
what how the is that your answer?"
Well, I don't I don't think so, dude. That's uh that's just very
funny. I'm sure that made Pixie feel like very comfortable, very
safe that not more of her stuff has been leaked anywhere, right?
Well, I don't I don't think so. I'm pretty sure not. Um, you
know, probably probably not. I think probably >> Reading
that probably doesn't help anything much.
So I don't really know why she's
>> so destiny when it serves Destiny. He'll totally dismiss
this message. Okay. This is somebody totally making up. This
is totally Well, dude, these people are just Well, you should
Pixie. Don't pay any attention to that. Whatever. I think that
Lauren told her that
they need to have something and that the best case scenario is
for me to admit some other kind of wrongdoing or to admit something
that like oh no like he we have to get him on something. I think
that this was kind of like a hail mary last stitch effort to
fish for
um me to
and you know what I think probably there's two there's two possibilities
here that there's what he just presented where it's like Lauren
de Laguna setting up a KF account as a lastditch effort to try
to you know get Destiny on some get Destiny on this [__]
The other possibility which is like astronom it's almost impossible.
Okay. The other possibility is Destiny is incredibly reckless
with who he sends to. He's incredibly reckless with whether or
not the person who any partners in that have consented to it
and he sends these things around. He machine guns them out and
and possibly that some people remember that and are annoyed by
it. I know that second one. Okay, that second
that's
that seems crazy. I know it's probably the first one. It's probably
the conspiracy.
It's probably the conspiracy, right? We definitely have way more
evidence for it being a conspiracy with Lauren de Laguna with
like um I think there's like some some post some text analysis
we've got coming up and um technically Pixie learned about a
new KF post within an hour of it happening. These seem like very
strong pieces of evidence. On the other hand, we have, you know,
Molina yelling at him about sending her non-consensually in
2021,
and then it happening again and it happening like multiple times
in this whole saga through these Rose leaks, right?
Yeah. Yeah. Okay.
Okay. Rose, obviously a fake post made by her legal team, which
she did not have yet, obviously, which is also funny. She did
not have her like current legal team or as far as I know like
really any representation at this point >> to admit to
doing something that I haven't done. And this was sent on January
18th.
So I don't remember what I was thinking about. Um it was something
to do with Trump. I think I think it was a meme where it's I
was I think I was just thinking of like a debate thing like what
would um like if Trump was trying to destroy America, what would
he do? Sometimes when you're trying to think of like uh if a
person is lying or doing something bad, you instead of just thinking
of like what they've done, think about like well what if they
were of a different state of mind, what would they actually do?
>> So something that I thought was really interesting was
that
>> is not reckless, he's careless. Desi is selfish and
doesn't care how it could affect the other people.
>> Both parties are allowed to issue subpoenas
and we have to make subpoenas available to the other side to
see what they're subpoenaing for. They subpoenaed Kiwi Farms.
They never asked for information though about this account. And
I thought that was very strange.
that could be interesting. Yeah. Very >> Accounts that
they do ask for information for.
And this one claimed to have had firstirhand knowledge or secondhand,
I guess to say, of somebody else receiving videos of the plaintiff.
And I was like,
>> Uh, am I wrong? Didn't null say they didn't ask for
any user data? Um,
no. They did ask for user data. I'm almost positive they asked
for user data because I think they
I think they asked for user data on Destiny and Null said, "Oh,
he deleted his account. Can't give you that." >> Well,
that's kind of weird. Wouldn't you Wouldn't you really want to
know who this was? It seems like it'd be important, right? >> It
could be. I'd need to know who else they requested information
from. The question you'd ask here, of course, is, well, given
the conspiracy you're about to unravel here.
Did you decide to subpoena this person? You didn't do any of
these things. You could have subpoenaed these people as well,
right? So, then I went back and I looked at this account and
then I see this account joined Kiwi Farms
at 8:07 p.m. on January 18th. And then I see that the first comment
that it made
it made at 8:19 p.m. 12 minutes later.
And then I see that at 9. When's the code cave comment from would
be a good question. Someone someone grabbed me this code cave
comment cuz that would be if she's if the person was making it
in response to that, that's not surprising that they would say,
"Hey, I just made my account in response to this, right? It's
literally in the first thing. This comment caused me to create
an account because I want it to be known that he has sent videos,
right? Give me a quote. Oh, something else to consider.
Rose would have been the only person he was doing this with.
Rose wouldn't have been the only won't Sorry. Rose won't have
been the only person he was doing this with. Yep. Okay, hold
on. Okay, so null's response here is I sent so when null was
asked about what was spinaed I sent them a list of messages deleted
invisible their edit history attachments and all moderation actions
taken in the thread. They did not broadly request user data but
and the user they did request data on I had nothing to provide
due to our retention policy. So this is null saying I believe
that they probably requested data on Destiny. I think so. So
might have only been Destiny. Yeah. Okay.
All right. 24 p.m. about an hour later,
Pixie is messaging me a screenshot
of a message from this account. Now, if this was November or
early December
when this first leaked, I could maybe buy that she's constantly
refreshing the page. Dude, for the amount of people who were
constantly refreshing this page, I would
one of them might have messaged her when this post was made and
said, "Hey, look, somebody just posted this like 10 minutes ago.
They say they sent a video of you." That seems like incredibly
pertinent information to Pixie.
Is it really that unbelievable that somebody with like Pixie's
at somewhere could have messaged this thread to her? Really doesn't
feel like it. and she was planning litigation against you too,
right? So obviously people around her could have been checking
this stuff. Anyway, we continue. But this is a little bit hard
to believe
that this account that has only made four posts ever
on Kiwi Farms, all four in my thread, three on the same day,
and then one on the 22nd. That she saw this post, screenshotted
it, and sent it to me about an hour. Isn't this the period during
which KF gets so overloaded with traffic that ship ship breaks?
No, it is not. No, it is not. That would be November, not this.
Anyway, hold on a second. Someone told me is J the code gave
comments January 18th. I would just want to know the time like
how far before this this would be >> after the creation
of the account. >> That's a good that's a good question,
Android. This is not the original blowup. Yeah. >> And
then the count has gone quiet since. Now, I will say one thing
I would want to note is it looked like the peach screenshot was
leaked from a male. She said that she said that it to him a year
ago and he's leaking it now because it fit the So, this person
in this other one seems to be somebody who would know this community
a little bit, know things about this community,
right? They know who Peach is, and they're just talking about
it normally. It seems like somebody who's either been lurking
the thread for a long time or like knows Desty's community. They're
making that reference. Wait, KF doesn't show time on posts older
than a few days. That can't possibly be true.
No, there's there's a way to get that. There's a way to get timestamps.
100% there would be.
Uh, if you mouse over that January 18th, it doesn't pop up with
a tool tip that gives you the time stamp. How has this guy been
pulling time stamps off these posts? Yeah, something something
would pull timestamps.
I didn't see this raw DM. Hold on. 5:30 p.m. Uh, or
>> if you click through the posts that this account makes
>> they do something that's kind of
>> Oh, let's go. So, actually, this is the full post here.
Hold on. The full post.
>> Hold on.
>> What is Ry saying here? Yeah. So, like 6:30. So technically
I believe it's about two hours.
>> Oh, hold on. Hold on.
>> Hold on. I just I want to I want to see because my my
hypothesis is basically that um it was probably like two to four
hours between the post that the person originally saw and them
making an account,
right? And so realistically, there's only about twice as fast
this got back to Pixie after that post was made, right? It's
it's like, oh, people do refresh these things like fairly often,
and if some new information breaks, people it will get passed
around. It will get like noticed by people very fast.
Uh, but I want to read this comment. It looked like the Peach
screenshot was leaked from a male. She said it she said that
to him a year ago, and he's leaking it now because it fit the
pattern of what's being uncovered. As for Oh, this is this the
Pickles DMs with Peach. As for other women, I could only imagine
they thought the person in the recording or video gave consent.
They might be coming out now because Pixie statement made them
reconsider the consent of the parties in the recordings of videos.
Jox said on his stream that Cherry said whoever showed her the
recording said after that day, I checked the recording again
and reconsidered if you were aware of it. I can't speak for them,
but personally, if someone sent me that material, I would not
automatically assume it was not consensual. Just my two cents.
Pixie statement might have made people who received material
reconsider. dot dot dot lots of dots. Lots of dot dot dots over
here. >> I really like to use ellipses of varying length
and they put a space afterwards
before their next character
>> as opposed to most people who use ellipses and don't
put a space. >> So here we have four periods in a space.
Four periods in a space.
>> Oh wait, wait. No way.
So hold on.
I'm I'm gonna show these.
>> So, his big proof that uh his big proof that Lauren
de Lagona is behind this
apparently, okay,
he doesn't believe that it's possible Pixie was refreshing the
thread, right?
>> But his big proof is, okay, we've got like these.
>> I believe this is the time stamp on the Code Cave post
that the new account is referencing, right? January 18th at 3:30
p.m. where these timestamps are from. And if we click on the
disaster cabbage post, okay, the this comment caused me to blah
blah blah. The time stamp is 5:19 p.m. So for them to have seen
this post and then decide to post themselves was an hour and
49 minutes,
Hour and Yeah.
49 minutes.
So,
so the idea is they couldn't have poss but somehow Lauren de
Laguna was refreshing enough to see the code cave post and go
oh comment quote actually this really this really
this comment made me think I need to go post something right
so the unforgivable time gap occur according to tourniquet is
an hour between this post happening and Pixie getting notified
of it but for Lauren de Laguna apparently she she must have been
spam refreshing the thread seen the code post and go now now's
my Now is my time. I can post now, right?
Like this is this is obviously goofy as
like people if you post new information in this thread, it will
go around. There are a lot of people who refresh this thread.
There a lot of people who connect who are connected to like the
DGG community refresh this thread. But if it's suspicious that
it took an hour for Pixie to see that and DM Destiny, then it's
I don't understand why this wouldn't be. Is Code Cave Lauren
de Lagona? Is Code Cave Jasmine Jafar? Is Code Cave
Farra
Faraci might be Code Cave?
What do you guys think? I just didn't think it was nearly as
ridiculous as y'all made it out. Dude, this is actually We're
going to get into We're going to get into some of the these ellipsies
are apparently Don't you guys know that Lauren de Laguna has
made tweets and Reddit posts with ellipses,
some of length three, some of length
And this is proof that I was set up from the beginning. This
ends with four
This one has five periods. >> Some with five periods. >> This
post that they make ends with a
>> three period ellipsy. >> A three period ellipsy.
>> This post that they made have a has a three period ellipsey
and a space before
>> Three period ellipsy and a space before the next character.
>> Three period ellipsy.
I don't remember if this was ever publicly announced or not,
but um that >> Oh, this is what really sells it. I think
is um I don't know why her tweets wouldn't sell it, but he knows
about some secret post that Lauren de Laguna made on Reddit.
>> Made a long time ago
on Reddit saying farmer bro Martini systematically abusing groups
of women without anyone noticing. So Lauren told me privately
this was her account. She's the one who made this post and then
she deleted it afterwards. But I noticed, >> when going
through her account >> that in several cases,
>> she has used >> she also types like this
dot dot dot dot space. I you not there are people in DGG chat
as this happens
typing cinema.
This man is a genius.
This man
is a genius.
We've We've figured it out. >> Space. That's so sweet.
>> I I love Hold on. I love how many times he has to click
through posts
to like find the next one. One, two, post. Got three four
>> One two three four space. Yeah. 1 2 3 4 space I 1 2
3 space. How do I do that? One, two, space ID. >> He skips
a lot of the posts where there aren't ellipses and then there
are some
>> wait, did he just miss one? I think you just missed
one.
>> Girls. Is there one? Oh, there isn't one there. I thought
there was one there. Damn. No. No. No. There we go. There. There's
one, two, three. Space. Do you think it's definitely not her,
though?
I don't have any real opinion that it's her or not. I think it'd
be absolutely insane for her to do that, right?
But I mean, I guess at minimum, it's not referenced in the complaint,
right? I just don't think this is actually strong evidence. I
think this is goofy.
>> 1 2 3 space now. One two three space
>> I think if he had suggested this I think this suggestion
is just absolutely wild to me that this could be what's like
like this is this is what he's been basing this entire conspiracy
off of this whole time, right? Is I think this is why I think
all of these people are conspiring and making up evidence against
me. This is why because of the ellipses. And then I also have
found the same if you go back through posts on Twitter. She also
types like this this one two three space but
one two three space but
IDK. What to tell you? >> She uses many ellipsies on Twitter.
>> I'm like 82% sure that this account was just created
by Lauren. I think
tourniquet 82%. Do you think this guy's taking 5 to1 odds? 4
to1 odds. Sorry. Think he's taking 4 to1 odds bets that it's
not Lauren de Laguna. That's ins tournate. We can agree that's
insane, right? 82%. This took me from 0.01%
to.1%.
I think 82%
from ellipses
and the fact that it was messaged to Pixie quickly. Neither of
these things seem relevant to me at all. I think that she told
Pixie that she was going to make this account and then post this
publicly so that they would have at least something kind of to
stand on for their complaint.
And I think the reason why they didn't ask farms about this account
when they subpoenaed it is because
that god damn it.
>> Hold on.
>> God damn it.
ask Kiwi Farms about this account when they subpoenaed it is
because if they got that information from KB Farms, they'd have
to turn it over to us and the only thing it ever show is that
it belonged to one of those two.
>> Okay. Does he Hold on.
>> Kind of wild he's actually pulling the thread up on
stream now. Oh, I didn't even think about that. Yeah, it is kind
of weird that he's directing people to the thread on stream,
isn't it? But uh again, it's all evidence that is in no way insane
like you guys want it to be. It's totally insane to alert to
allege this. And it's probably, in my opinion, totally insane
to allege that it's them or or that if they were doing this,
like why in the world would they not look something up? Why would
they not look up like a VPN? How in the world would this tie
back to them? Right? And then I mean there's also the fact that
why would they not add it to the complaint or it's it's like
not near the complaint at all.
>> Like
this is actually nowhere near the complaint. This is not in the
complaint at all.
Right. And yeah,
>> dude I
sorry when I said 0.01 01 to like
I that is really what it is like 0.1. There's like no way it's
lower daily,
>> right? Why?
How would this help?
>> I don't understand how this would help.
>> Can he actually substantiate what he's saying? Why is
he speculating? I have no
The actual Reddit thread. Oh, the Lauren de Laguna one. I just
Yeah, I just don't think it's like uh like trendy enough. And
a lot of people do use like ellipsies. Maybe not the four times
ellipsies or something, but I think he had one instance of her
doing that ever. Is Destiny going to sue them? I have no idea
what he wants to do. >> That's why she was able to message
me an hour after it posted. I think she told >> Oh, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait. There is an interesting theory though
that Lauren de Laguna posits for this.
>> A very interesting theory. Hold on.
>> Oh, hold on.
Oh, we will be going through some of the the Fentes clips from
tonight because apparently this guy's losing it. We go through
some of that stuff.
Dude,
imagine trying to ruin Pixie's birthday two years in a row because
you have no friends and no family who care about you. Imagine
creating accounts on KF to ruin people's life. That then prove
it's me. subpoena, dude.
so apparently it's Pixie's birthday. He happened to come up with
this unique theory where you could show Kiwi Farms in his Kiwi
Farms thread and talk about the case on his birthday. On her
birthday. Amazing.
Amazing. Amazing. She does say just subpoena it. There's uh one
other thing here. What is it?
There's another post where she says like just subpoena it. Hold
on. Pull it. Let me pull it. Let me pull it. Okay,
imagine being a literal skitsoid rant.
>> Cool, cool, cool, cool.
>> Imagine being this dumb. Destiny, please subpoena the
account owner to prove it isn't me. I, as an attorney, know you
can do that. Hence, never made a fake account to talk about you.
The only things I've ever said about you, I say proudly, is Lauren
Hayden. I, Lauren Hayden, find you disgusting.
Okay, tourniquet. Tourniquet,
I want you to give me your percentage and then let's throw a
bet. >> Let's throw a bet. >> I want you to give
me your percentage. Just give me your hypothetical percentage
because we'll probably never be able to close the bet.
>> Do you know how to read? I have not been looking for
your percentage. Do you have a percentage?
>> Turn, can you give me a percentage for what? Not ridiculous
is I'm just
>> Didn't say no. Their retention policy drama 101. The
retention policy would mean if your stuff's deleted, they won't
retain it for a certain amount of time,
>> Equally as unlikely as likely,
even though 50/50 is stupid and
It's just not crazy because Lauren has a history of doing this
with Martin.
>> All right.
>> Comparison of writing styles. Apparently apparently
Riy threw it through. If you guys are interested, Ri threw it
through um chat to compare the writing styles.
I don't even I have no idea how valid this might be, but you
know what? I'll read it for two seconds. Wring styles of user
one and two are marketably different across several key areas.
Use one. The tone is highly emotional, volatile, and deeply personal.
Just rapidly between defensiveness. What do you think I'm doing
posing this? Aggression. Sue me. Vulnerability. I'm seriously
upset about not having a man who I love touch me. And sarcasm.
Lol. Okay. Okay. I sounded like a writing is a direct unfiltered
expression of personal experience and trauma. User two. The tone
is measured. Analytical is focused on reporting information.
He has sent video to my friend analyzing the situation. Yeah.
Uh
so it's two different situations. Since Lauren is in one situation
reporting on herself and then this person would be a third party
reporting on Pixie. Go to the last step if you want the summary.
I just want the what do you call it? The sentence structure.
Sure. Short often fragment fragmented se uh sentences of him.
No, he's okay there. Punctuation is used for dramatic effect
and emotional emphasis with a heavy reliance on exclamation points.
Often multiple like exclamation point exclamation point and ellipses
dot dot dot dot. These are more complex multi- clause sentences.
This comment caused me to create an account because I want it
to be known that he sent the video.
This is the Reddit versus the Kiwi Farm stuff. I mean, there's
not really enough post to say for sure. That's another reason
it's like silly, but I just think it's funny that um
they came up with this plan
within like an hour.
Within an hour, they had made the account, right,
and made the post. Sorry, within an hour and a half, basically,
they they were like, "Okay, we have take an hour and a half.
We know we're going to make an account and then we're going to
make a
that seems like that that we think that could be possible. Just
seems crazy.
>> I'm going to make this account, post his thing, send
a screenshot to Steven, see if you can get him to admit that
he did something else because we don't really have anything else
for this complaint. Um, tell him you can kill himself if he doesn't
say anything.
But I
So, anyway, you can prove this. I think that Kiwi Farms doesn't
hold information for more than a couple months. And I think that
um so I don't think >> they wouldn't hold like deleted
>> right? But you don't know if this person's logged in
again. >> I I don't think I could ever really
>> Why wouldn't you subpoena them and try? The answer to
that is because that could lead them to a different um that that
this is Lauren De Laguna. That is way more useful to him than
trying to prove this out obviously. >> How did you figure
this out? Um, I don't know why you wouldn't want all the information
you could on somebody who's claiming to have gotten these videos.
>> Lauren coaching her so much in the background and knowing
that they had nothing. And so now at this point, by the way,
Lauren coaching her so much in the background. This is said as
a foregone conclusion.
Right? Lauren de Laguna has said, "I'm a lawyer. The only advice
I gave Pixie is to get a lawyer because I can't advise her because
I have a conflict."
>> They're trying to amend the complaint. They're trying
to add the Abby stuff, which they also know is a lie because
again, I don't I can't read you the transcript directly, but
in court they admitted that they had no evidence of me sending
Abby anything. She said that under oath. Um, it's just it's like
the whole goal is to just drag this out like as much as possible.
That's it. But
what a meme. There you go.
>> Okay. The Abby stuff. Do you actually believe that?
Do I actually believe? Yes, I do actually believe that. I believe
that Lauren de Laguna basically told Pixie, you have to get a
lawyer. I can be your friend, but I can't be legal counsel for
you.
>> Everybody knows that. Everybody knows that that's what
you should do, right? In that situation, you don't give legal
advice to the person because one, if you're emotional, you're
not going to give good legal advice. You don't want that. You
don't want the person to blame you for [__] their
case getting up, right? Why wouldn't you believe that?
>> Oh, baby.
>> Yes. Like Lauren would support Pixie and she would hate
Destiny obviously,
right?
>> No evidence except the contemporary statements made
to a third party. I don't even Are you talking about
Contemp contemporary doesn't mean anything. Are there contemporaneous
statements made? Oh, he's saying yes. Yes. Yes. I get what you're
saying.
did he just say no, no, no, no, no, no. The way he phrases this,
sorry, I'm not paying DMs because again, I don't I can't read
you the transcript directly, but in court, they admitted that
they had no evidence of me sending Abby anything. She said that
under
>> uh so she said that this would be Pixie. He's saying
Pixie said that. But what they had said from the very beginning,
as we all know, okay, when we pull up the Abby MC affidavit,
is that Abby said she did not have any pictures of Desi sending
the video because he had deleted his DMs with her, thereby deleting
the video from the DMs. Right? Anything to do with the video,
deleted from the DMs. What she claimed from the very beginning
with her affidavit. So, he says she's lying, but her evidence
provided actually perfectly backs up her affidavit. One to one,
100%. Yes. She said, "I have contemporaneous DMs that I've taken
screenshots of to friends that they can confirm like I was saying
in 2023 that I got these videos." Right? That's what her affidavit
says and that's what she provided.
anyway, anyway, does the courts care about that or Yeah, the
court would care about that. Yes.
That would be evidence that gets you to like discovery that gets
you to potentially like a trial, right?
>> Um, did it turn out that bad empanada found Rose or
was he reaching? He was reaching. He didn't know anything.
>> You think he's just doing this to make himself look
more like a victim to his audience or do you think he actually
believes Lauren wrote it? Uh h
he's narcissistic enough that he so he's like sitting here and
he's like well there's no way that like I'm not the victim here
so these people are conspiring against me. There's no way my
actions came to bite back to bite me in the ass. So like these
people have to be conspiring against me. And I had no idea why
in the world he had like such a conspiratorial mindset. But if
you had that DM from Pixie and then he like was looking at this
stuff, I think he is for some reason getting like cuz honestly
in my head when I watch the lawsuit I'm like, "Oh, the lawsuit's
going like okay for him, right? I'm sure he's paying out the
apps for his lawyers, but I don't really think he's like losing
the lawsuit." Um there's like nothing. So it's all just waiting
on discovery and what comes back from subpoenas, right? That's
basically what the lawsuit is is just waiting on what comes back
from subpoenas. There's a lot of window dressing on the side
with the protective order, the the preliminary injunction, this
stuff, but it's basically just waiting for what can we subpoena
and when do we get it back and is there evidence of what we're
looking for? That's basically
everything they're waiting on. That's what we'll decide like
this entire thing. And the Abby stuff is important to get to
that, right?
He doesn't believe Lauren wrote it or he would just request access
to the account he claims is Lauren, the one who messaged Pixie
through Discovery. But he won't because he knows he's full of
Well, that's the thing is like, so he referenced the sister thing
and he's basically trying to cast dispersions on on the mentioned
in the complaint, right? Like he's basically saying this is fake.
This is a lie. If he thinks this is a lie, shouldn't he just
be able to ask for evidence of this?
Although maybe if it's just a complaint and they're they maybe
they I don't even know if they have to produce evidence of it
to be honest. They might not. They might just be able to say
this in a
>> Destiny said on stream's already up 250k in lawyer fees.
Damn. Did you watch that tourniquet clip? Nope. What is it?
>> Loner box catches Lauren de Lagona
What is this? This isn't loading. The This literally isn't loading
for me at all. What's going on?
>> Yeah, this is just not working. I was Is Pixie still
going on the case if Destiny is spending that much? Dessi's got
like the most expensive lawyers on planet Earth. Oh, it's just
Yeah. Okay.
I got it. I got it. We're good.
>> I don't want to put you I don't want to put you on
>> Um I don't want to >> I don't want to put you
I don't want to put you on the spot.
>> Did you leave a comment in one of my videos saying that
I lied about the history that Ben Shapiro was lying
No, that wasn't No, I do sometimes have people who do like my
uh like Lauren de Laguna and like take my face and then like
that's like me. But no, I I didn't I What? >> You have
imposters.
>> I do, but um I I don't even post really about Israel
Palestine on Twitter. I don't really like to touch the subject
Israel Palestine. I was asked to be on a kick or keep about Israel
Palestine and I pulled out the only debate I've done so far on
Israel Palestine is the one with you in which basically I just
sat there saying I don't know enough information to really comment.
So that's kind of been it I haven't been in your comments. Um
I actually like your content. I like to listen to people who
disagree with me so that I could hear the other side. I don't
I think I've been watching you but I haven't been in your chat.
She just openly lying based. I don't think I've commented at
all.
>> Maybe. I don't think I have. >> Do you have a
YouTube channel called Lauren De Lagona?
>> Not legal advice, not a licensed
>> Yeah, that's me. >> Okay. Um,
I remember commenting. I don't think I don't think you're a
I don't >> What was the What was the comment? What was
the actual comment? He pulled it up,
disagree with me. So that >> use the same incorrect information
about denying peace agreements for two decades in this video
that you did in the debate last night. That's the main issue
three weeks ago. Yeah, that's a weird thing to lie about to be
honest with you. >> I don't I think >> Okay, it might
have. Hold on. The fact that she'd lie about this is not even
remotely close to evidence that she'd lie about the other thing.
>> It's Sorry. One of these things is her lying in an embarrassing
situation. The other one is her doing conduct that would get
her disbarred automatically
and like not really close to me. Also, they're totally different
kinds of things. Like this is the kind of thing you do as out
of like awkwardness where you're like, "Uh, I hope he doesn't
know about that." >> Think I've been watching you but I
haven't been in your chat like or something about
>> that she claims imposters are out there pretending to
be her.
>> maybe I don't think I have. >> Do you have a YouTube
channel called Lauren De Laguna?
>> not legal advice, not a licensed
>> Uh,
I think she's just lying. She got really uncomfortable when when
asked. >> I was asked to be on a kick or keep about Israel
Palestine and I pulled out the only debate I've done. So, what
>> you have imposters?
>> I do, but um I I don't even post really about Israel
Palestine on Twitter. I don't really like to touch this subject.
Israel Palest >> she's just lying. Doesn't mean that you
go and do that, right? And again, the idea that it's coordinated
is the hour difference between the post being made and Pixie
finding out about it and messaging Destiny,
whereas like the po the post that it's referencing was made like
an hour and a half, hour and 40 minutes before,
right? So that person had to make the account before quoting
to reference.
That's like a far less believable time period. I feel like there's
as much reason to believe Code Cave is the person making that
post. Yeah, I have no idea. I have no idea why she lied. This
is just like a weird lie over here. Oh man, I would love to see
some of the comments on this. It's very goofy. The point is that
she didn't mean to post that from her main.
Maybe not. Oh wait, hold on. Can we go? Hold on. Wait. I got
to pull that back up. How many ellipsies are in the post?
>> How many ellipsies? Okay, if we have if we have
if we have ellipses of differing length within the post, it's
100% guaranteed that that poster is Lauren de Lagona. We have
ellipses of only one length, it's like a 50/50. Okay. >> Sat
there saying I have listened to >> Where are these? Where
are these? Where are these? >> Agree with me so that I
could hear the other side. >> Oh, no ellipsies. No ellipsies
in the
No ellipsies in the post.
Zero ellipsies.
No ellipsies in the Lauren de Laguna post. Unfortunate. She's
trying to sound like an anon. Oh, and when she was posting on
Kiwi Farms, what was she trying to sound like if she were tourniquet?
Why would Why would the post on Kiwi Farms not try to sound like
an anon if she's familiar with how to do >> You, sir, are
drunk and you've lost your own argument. You've gone off the
rails.
There's no hope for you.
Resounding tourniquet L.
Think I was being serious there? I don't think I was being serious
either when I said there's a 100% chance that there's ellipsies
that it's her
>> like the Michael Jordan meme. I just want to see where's
that other post? The one with the the ellipsies.
Bro, I dude
some crazy going on in the world recently. I can't believe every
time I watch every time I maybe I only get linked the worst,
but every time I get linked to Destiny stream, it's like more
disappointing than the last. I don't even know how they do it.
How do they keep making this worse every time?
How do they keep getting worse and worse and worse and worse?
>> Um, oh, also I missed the one thing. The one thing I
noticed when I watched like the first five minutes of that before
was he does say this is like only a what? He says it's like only
a day before they they file the case. And that's not true. It's
a day before. Oh, hold on. I'll just find it. I'll just find
it so I can explain it.
>> Oh god. It's going to have to be
>> Where is it? Here. My life for thousands to see. So
this is on January 18th
about a day day and a half before she they actually filed the
uh complaint. >> So that's not true. So that's like that
makes it sound
way more compelling that it's a day or a day and a half before
they filed the complaint. Of course, it's about a month before
they filed the complaint, right? I believe they filed the complaint
on February 18th.
Is that correct? February 18th, guys. I get that date right.
>> Uh I do have that date correct. Date filed February
18th,
So this there was no court filing. She might not have even had
legal representation at this point. Actual legal representation,
right?
>> She uh I think there's no reason to believe she wasn't
like actually in this state in this mental state. Michael Jordan
meme fraternic kid. No, I'm good.
>> He means she went public. Uh she could mean she went
public, but that's not what he says.
And she didn't go public. Sunday went public. Right. Sunday and
Becket went public. She scrambled, panicked, published some stuff
that she was working on.
>> The total disorganization of her original file, her
original um Substack and stuff, all of that, how disorganized
that was.
Obviously, she was forced, right? She was she was like in a panic
and she posted stuff. But it looks I don't know how it looks.
Um what do you call it? What day was your substack posted? uh
January 20th,
I believe, or 21st, but I'm pretty sure 20th. But the idea is
um she can't survive a So, the idea is for litigation, she can't
survive a motion to terminate without more evidence, right? That's
the theory he's proposing. I'm not even convinced she had legal
representation at this time. Lauren did help Pixie with the give
and go thing though, right? Well, they had to get it up that
day. I would imagine if um if suddenly people had posted videos
and Pixu is freaking the out and Lauren de Laguna is one of her
closest friends, she might come over and go, "Oh, I I can help
you get some stuff organized."
Right? I'll help you get like the give and go going. I'll help
you um get your substack up. Maybe I can help register something,
right?
But I do believe she stuck away from giving legal advice because
that would that could be like really threatening to >> and
that would be the reason she'd stick away and say like, "Hey,
I have friends who are lawyers. I'll just give you one of their
numbers." >> Yeah, sure, Silver. That would make sense
as well.
>> but yeah, I would just go and
that would be my big question is like did Pixie I don't believe
there's a reason to believe that Pixie had significant legal
representation. She didn't even get her initial complaint filed
for a full month after this.
>> If she'd gotten her complaint filed like in a timely
fashion maybe,
but I don't even think I think when did they get their what do
you call it? Their thing to preserve evidence. When did that
hit Destiny? I don't even know if you could see it. I wonder
when he got those letters. Actually, wait, wait, wait. Initial
complaint. When did he get Actually, I just totally up. What
we should be looking for is when he got his initial, what do
you call it? Demand letter, right? When did he get that? Is that
specified here?
Is that specified anywhere? Have we gotten a date on that? When
the when Pixie's representation first reached out to him? Because
if she had representation and they were telling her, "Hey, we
need to try to get this."
Why did it take them like so long to reach out? Or maybe it didn't.
Maybe I'm just unaware and they actually reach out on the 20th
like the legal representation did. That would prove me totally
wrong here if they if they did
All right. Well,
>> what time is it? Now, is it time to play? It's time
to play Civ finally. Is it finally time to play Civ?
>> It might be. Might just be.
>> Wait. So, what happened to Kelly and all that? Um, she
left the Discord and I don't think we're friends anymore, apparently.
So, she'll be back. I don't think she'll be back. She should
cry, baby. I
don't know. I'm like fine with her being angry, but I think um
the issue with Kelly is that she like feels disrespected. And
I'm like, Kelly, even when I'm like disrespecting you, I feel
like I treat you with like 10 or 100 times more respect than
you treat me. And so, I don't know how it's like when I match
energy, I feel like then suddenly I'm being a complete [__]
Loki Coco, she is up, but I think um man, she's up, but I don't
know. I don't know. I feel like that's like not necessarily true.
We'll see. Okay, what do we Hold on. Let's check a few out real
quick and then we can end the stream. Somebody linked me one.
Let's go look at like Delrope or something. Del.
And above all else, uh you know, put some respect on my name.
And I hit the nail on my head at the end. I kind of >> not
a good misspeak for the start. I hit the nail on my head. went
off
and I said, "Look, I was 17. What's your
You know, you got married later than me. You got redpilled later
than me. You became a trutht teller later than me. And you haven't
gone through a fraction of
uh I was a C++ programmer tourniquet.
My first and second job. Okay. No, my first job.
And not really that much, but I've I've coded a bunch of languages.
I've I've written an actual operating system in like assembly
and C. I don't know why you think I don't know like low-level
languages. I absolutely do. >> Of what I've gone through
and >> sh this guy who's Oh, you're just totally trolling.
Oh, you can go for the night. Bye. I'm sorry it took me so long
to understand. I didn't I didn't realize you shouldn't this guy
who's 5 years of experience in finance like a loser >> and
she wants to call me out. >> But you actually got me. You
actually got me. Also, if you weren't trolling, you just at me
in the Discord cuz I'm pretty sure you were. But I I feel bad
that it took me that long to figure it >> That's what she
texted me. She goes, "I'm calling you out."
And my response to that is, "Bitch, you have no right to call
me, and maybe it's time for you as a woman, to sit down and shut
the up."
>> That's me, a man, you want to say, "Make me a sandwich."
Okay, this is me, a man, telling you, a woman, to sit down and
shut the up before you call out anybody else. sit down and shut
the up. I'm so sick of it. She's got her book, Make Me a Sandwich.
That's the book cover. Her book cover is her sitting cross-legged.
I'm going to sit her Her her book is her sitting cross-legged.
Make him a
Okay. Okay. You want You want that, huh? All right.
Okay. Turn has informed me that he is not trolling.
And you said not a C++ gamer or gamedev. Turn. What do you think
the vast majority of like network code is written in? I'm legitimately
curious.
Do you think there's not a ton of network code written in C or
C++? That's >> Well, hey, listen. Daddy's home. >> That's
crazy, dog.
>> Hey, a real man is home. I'm pulling up my sle my sleeves.
You want to call me out? Sit down and shut the up.
That's what a man has to say. And make me a sandwich and make
it good.
Turkey and
Can you handle that? But I did eat last night. Turkey and proalone.
That's how I And honestly, that's how I feel about it. Yeah.
Make him a sandwich. >> It's like not that impressive a
rant to be honest. Everybody who's like, "This is a really good
rant." This is not one of the all-time funnest rants. It's not
even good. >> And then she's gonna give me then she's going
to give She texts me on Friday, I'm calling you out. I've had
enough of you calling me out.
You cannot call me out. One, you are a woman. Two, you have not
gone through a fraction of what I have gone through.
You know nothing.
I have been on this since 2017, since I was 18 years old. You
want to call me out? And that's honestly, that's the epitome
of it all. Before you call out anybody,
how about a shred of humility?
How about an ounce
of self-awareness?
Why don't you observe the fact that while you had a contract
at Daily Wire, Turning Point USA, Infowars, book deals, and by
the way,
because you're a black woman, because you are a semiarticulate
black woman, you're like Obama. She don't talk with that dialect.
She was a black woman who did the conservative grip and she rode
that tokenism doing
exit for 10 years making millions of dollars and then married
into a wealthy family and then discovered there's something going
on with Israel after everybody after only everybody started to
notice. Now you want to call me out the OG.
Well, that was your first mistake. >> Okay. I'm very very
sorry. Okay, this is not impressive after you kind of got punked
a little bit by Candace live. Okay, this is like this is like
a shower thoughts rant right here. I would have liked to if if
I saw this energy with Candace, you know, maybe a little bit.
Hey, that's different.
>> But this is like a shower thoughts rant right now. >> Where's
the energy when you're in the
>> Am I crazy? Am I the only one seeing
I'm telling Turnigan to join the VC. Just watch. We We'll just
watch the first video and watch his actual criticism. You can
see what he's capable of by himself,
right? I He might have done a better video later with somebody
explaining to him how to make the actual critiques, but that
doesn't matter to me. We just watch his first video.
You can go through it and you can explain to me why you think
the critiques are good and why this guy's smart because he has
five years of experience C++.
>> I can I read that tourniquet? Can I read that last line?
Because that is an insane excuse. Or do I have to Is that going
to be a problem?
>> Can I read that?
Okay, we can discuss it another night
>> He can't. He's uh he's doing stuff.
Can't discuss it tonight. That's too
Turn can't be on VC yelling.
No, it's fine. Okay. He said, "Okay, I'm at my best friend's
house with a baby in the next room to me. Otherwise,
I would you know that? Well, I don't know if I know that, but
I just think it's really funny that you're like, "This guy's
five years of experience in C++."
As if that's like uh
at a finance shop. At a finance shop, not lame. That's wholesome.
I didn't say it was Oh, I said it was lame as in you're here
chatting it up. You're here chatting it up. What is this?
I don't like laughing at this cuz it
>> it feeds into the propaganda that Epstein was actually
dead.
>> I don't like to I don't like to uh endorse this propaganda
that Epstein's actually dead. Okay, he ain't dead. No, he ain't
dead. Okay,
this is real, right? Even though I don't know where this account's
from.
>> Didn't this actually happen that like Gain Maxwell was
like, "I'll give you guys the list." And House Republicans are
like, "No, we don't need the list.
>> No, we don't need the list.
There's some joke here about how fanboys became
or fanboys. Yeah, fanboy. Okay, it's some joke. There's something.
>> Wait, what?
Where? Where? Where? Dwight.
Seems like you already know where.
>> Oh boy. >> Oh boy.
>> Well, Stencil just had an incredible save roll on his
Jesus.
>> You think the pulling perms was a bit of an overcorrection?
>> uh, yeah, I was just annoyed. I was I get annoyed when
people like I ask a direct question and people are like
>> give me totally evasive answers. I get like annoyed.
>> But hey, it is what it is.
>> Do you tell us where to send them for those that don't
get the joke? Um to historical Palestine where they belong. They
should all be in historical
>> Okay. Sorry. I'm I'm kind of dying to be honest. So,
>> where is that? You know where that is. You know where
that is. Why are you pretending you don't know where that is?
You know where that is. Okay.
it
for us. I miss Kelly already. True.
>> One more turn. Uh, yeah, we'll see. Maybe tomorrow.
>> Great content today. It didn't feel great. Felt weird,
but it is what it is. All right, I'll be back
tomorrow.
Have a good night, guys. I'll hopefully be back tomorrow earlier
or something. Okay, have a good night. Bye. Good night.